[Music]  I see the moon sees me leave the old  trees the vehicles not safe  we need to fail we need to fail down  here so we don't fail up there please  so you know everyone's in agreement we'd  like you to command  [Music]  well what's wrong  you think it has gone to the moon  - yeah  the entire world's watching I do you  question whether the program's worth the  cost in money in amongst one of the  chances are not coming back oh those  kids they don't have a father anymore  great so you're gonna sit the boys down  and you're gonna prepare them for the  fat you might not ever come home what do  you think you're coming back  we have serious bubbles  we've got this under control you're a  bunch of boys you don't have anything  under control  [Music]  you  you